invited here as guest
of rabbi gazinski who's standing in my
immediate right
and we're going to apologize for some of
the logistics
as all of you know this was a
rather ad hoc affair
it's been pulled together literally in
the last
hours
and we had an intervening shabbat
so not
nothing could be done
from friday night until saturday night
so we will appreciate everyone's
patience
i'd like to thank rabbi gazinski and his
robertson connie vicente
for opening up the
chabad house to this important event
you're in a base chabad
this room serves as a house of worship
as a synagogue
in the jewish world
the synagogue
immediately becomes
following prayer
a base midnight
a place of learning
madras
ultimately
means speech
in khasidut
we know that there are three important
vessels
for the soul of the individual a soul
that we all have
those three important vessels are
makshava
the principal matter
is what you do
having said that however
we know that debor or speech
are holy vessels
there will not be a word
out of anyone's mouth it is not a vessel
for holiness
or its opposite god forbid
it is a vessel
so it is important
that as we
gather here this morning
to speak
and to exercise
our god-given right through speech
and our american right to free speech
that we do so civilly
we do so with
courteousness
and we do so with menstrual types
before we go any further
it is incumbent on all of us to say the
pledge of allegiance
to the flag so i would ask everyone to
please rise
and follow after me
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all it wasn't too long ago
that i was invited to speak on the
question of sharia the threat doctrine
that derives from that
the threat to
our freedom
and our liberties
and i was given a form
to speak
on shabbat
and then the following sunday
robby park off sat to my immediate left
during the discussions
and in so far as
bobby parkoff is the leader
and the rabbi of the great next
synagogue i can only echo
what jeff said
there is no shortage of leadership and
courage in the jewish community in great
neck
it is manifest
through the men's club of great neck
synagogue it's manifest through the
leadership of the great neck synagogue
led by rabbi apollokov
it's led
by rabbi gazinski and robertson
gaiczynski here at the chabad house
and it's led by all of you
like many others
i had been involved in public policy and
national security questions all my
professional career it wasn't until 9 11
that
i had what oftentimes is referred to as
an epiphany
i realized that the threat that we had
imagined
the threat that we had thought
and i'm talking about the professional
level was one based upon real estate
or political
issues turned out to be something
different
the narrative
that worldwide terrorism was a
palestinian cause
and methodology
to achieve political
sovereignty in the middle east
turned out not to fit the facts
we had already experienced in the 1990s
with the uss cole
the various attacks on embassies
that were not the product of a
palestinian or a palestinian cause
but it took 911 the shock that we all as
americans felt
to wake up and understand that
narratives are fine
for fairy tales
but if you're going to confront an enemy
and if you're going to confront an enemy
at a professional level you'd better pay
attention to the facts
so we looked around
and we began each of us independently
searching for
the connecting dots
i won't get into the substance of what
pamela geller might speak about we
haven't even spoken about what she
intends to talk about here
but having represented her across the
united states in federal court
in the trademark office
in state courts
where either we're suing for her right
to speak
for example
here in new york
when groups were running anti-israel ads
and blaming israel and the united states
and financial aid for all the problems
pamela decided to run with her partner
robert spencer an ad that was quite
simple straightforward
in any war between a civilized man and a
savage
support the civilized management
stop g.i
stop jihad support israel simple ad did
not insult the people
did not insult a religion
indeed i dare say that the savages to
whom she referred
would probably
agree that that's
the description of their own behavior
the new york city mta having run the
anti-israel ads refused to run her ads
the decision makers were
individuals lawyers executives many of
them jewish
but they simply said we're not going to
run the ad because it's disparaging
when pam aguela asked well is it not
disparaging of jews and israelis
that you blame violence on them
and on america for financial aid
and the answer was it's different
because your speech
might
result in violence
and pamela geller asked
i'm not violent
my friends aren't violent
our speech is not violent and it doesn't
call for violence so who's going to be
violent
all of a sudden the room is silent
we go into federal court in front of
judge paul engelmeyer
a new judge and a bright one
and he looked at the mta after a full
day of hearing and testimony and said i
don't get it
there's a first amendment
you are censoring ms geller's speech
based upon its viewpoint and content
and in this country
that's illegal
pamela geller and many others but
especially pamela giller
because she exercises her free speech
courageously civilly
but courageously
in venues and context
that would frighten
the most courageous of men
one final little anecdote and i'm going
to turn it over to our guest speaker
today
when a little muslim girl
in ohio
decided she wanted to leave islam
and exercise her right
to freedom of religion she was 17 years
old
when at least it was discovered
and her father discovered
that she wanted
to change her religion
he threatened to kill her in an honor
killing
she left home
ran away
to fellow parishioners in florida where
she was sheltered for a while
until the parents found out
went to the authorities went to court
and forced the florida
authorities to return her to ohio
there was a custody battle
and throughout this process pamela
geller at her website atwoodshrugs.com
wrote and covered the story she pounded
on the story
that this little girl should not be sent
to a home will she'll be murdered in an
honor killing
as a result
the ohio authorities
agreed that she would remain in state
custody not be returned home and when
she would turn to 18 and emancipated she
left
as a result of miss geller's
courageous reporting and she was
singular
in covering this story to keep the
spotlight on the authorities so this
little girl wouldn't simply be shuttled
back into a home to be murdered
which occurs daily
not only
in other parts of the world but right
here in the united states and you can
see those
events captured on ms geller's website
miss geller was sued
she was sued by one of the attorneys for
the little girl who happened to be
associated with the council on american
islamic relations or care
i hear
some recognition of care
care is a muslim brotherhood hamas front
group
it's been
it's
been identified as such by the united
states government
in federal criminal trials
it remains free to operate
it remains free to claim 501c3 status as
a charitable organization
and it remains free to receive funds
from overseas you can imagine where
and to spend their money
attacking
our free speech and our liberty in the
disguise
of a civil rights organization
he sued ms geller for 10
million dollars
he had all the weight
of the organization behind him
pamela came to us my partner and i
robert muse
we took on the case
and it took a year and a half
a year and a half
but eventually
the plaintiff caved in
dismissed the lawsuit
but that is the kind of assault ms
gelber is up against every single day
the protest here in great neck
are nothing
in fact i would suggest
that the protest over her willingness to
speak to us
and for us to be willing to listen to
her here
are a good sign